[Music]
we begin in Northern Kosovo where
demonstrations have turned violent at
least 41 NATO peacekeepers and 52 ethnic
serbs were injured when fighting broke
out during a protest against ethnic
Albanian Mayors taking office acid bake
reports from the town of zvetgan
this is not the de-escalation NATO the
EU and the U.S called for
instead its NATO forces known as K4 that
came under attack
sir protesters in zwechan through tear
gas and stun grenades at the soldiers
some of whom suffered fractures and
burns
Kosovo president viosa usmani accused
Serbian president Alexander verucic of
destabilizing Kosovo serves also painted
the letter Z on police and NATO Vehicles
referring to a Russian sign used in the
war in Ukraine for its part the
government in Serbia has been cautious
in its dealings with Ally Russia and the
West over the Ukraine conflict
Earl during the day serbs tried to take
over a local government building in the
town resveration in northern Kosovo
but we're pushed back by Kosovo police
officers
anger has risen among serbs since Friday
when ethnic Albanian Mayors tried to
take over and serve majority areas in
Kosovo ethnic serbs here have never
recognized its self-declared
independence in 2008. they see
themselves as part of Serbia
illegal ultimate sheriffs the way they
call themselves the newly elected Mayors
go to their homes and that all of the
special forces that are currently in the
town hall and around the town hall pull
out because this is not a police station
this is the people's Town Hall
serbs here don't recognize Kosovo
institutions they don't pay tax in
Kosovo and boycotted local elections in
four municipalities last month
the turnout was less than 3.5 percent I
work in Serbian company it's a
healthcare
dentist technician so
only who pay Serbian people here is
Serbia
uh you can't live without money yeah so
Albanian like them in Albania not
Christian and not uh and
it's the first place Richard because
this is a Serbian land kosovo's prime
minister has said the country needs to
uphold this constitution one of the
elected mayor says the protests have
nothing to do with democracy
criminal gangs are making efforts to
hinder security the rule of law and to
obstruct the processes to move kosovo's
institutions forward these groups
inspired by various Serbian Russian
Services strongly supported even by
Serbia itself are causing these problems
they are obstructing the establishment
of a reliable legal infrastructure in
the Republic of Kosovo
in North Kosovo ethnic servicing
nationalistic songs and wave Serbian
Flags but others fear the greater
autonomy they ask for could become a
step towards this area becoming a part
of Serbia NATO forces say they've
increased their presence in the North
but with the war in Ukraine and Serbia's
close relationship with Russia Western
powers are Keen to avoid another
conflict in the region their fragile
peace remains difficult with people here
not willing to back down and Kosovo
police continuing to maintain the
presence outside municipality buildings
tensions here seems set to continue
Assad Kosovo
Serbia's President Alexander vucic has
addressed the violence Bernard Smith has
more from Belgrade
among the NATO peacekeepers injured in
those confrontations with ethnic serbs
in Northern Kosovo are hungarians and
Italians and their governments say some
of them have been seriously injured and
more than 50 serbs have been injured
according to the government here three
of them seriously Serbian President
Alexander vouchic is calling on serbs to
protest peacefully
I'm emerging the serbs in Kosovo and I
know how they feel and how difficult it
is for them not to get into a conflict
with NATO not because I'm afraid or
because any of us are afraid none of us
personally have anything to lose but
because that's what kert who wants most
vouchage is referring there to Albin
curti the kosovan Prime Minister and he
blames him for this escalation in
violence vouchic says he'll be visiting
his troops they remain on high alert and
will be moving closer to the border with
Kosovo although any direct confrontation
between NATO forces and Serbian forces
would be an extraordinary escalation and
is unlikely and vouchic is calling for a
meeting on Tuesday with diplomats from
the U.S Germany the UK France and Italy
now there have been frequent outbreaks
of violence and confrontations in
Northern Kosovo the ethnic serbs living
there have never accepted kosovo's
unilateral Declaration of Independence
back in 2008 but this outbreak of
violence the violence is perhaps the
most serious there's been there since
then
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Belgrade